STRATEGY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AT SOME POINT IN LIFE, WE ALL
HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER WE WANT
TO BE VICTIMS OR VICTORS.
DO WE WANT TO BE DEFINED BY
SLIGHTS AND WRONGS?
ONES THAT ARE PERCEIVED OR REAL?
THAT WE SUFFER AT THE HANDS OF
OTHERS.
242 YEARS AGO, OUR FOREFATHERS
MADE THE DECISION THAT KIND OF
SITTING AROUND BEMOANING OUR
FATE UNDER BRITISH RULE WASN'T
GOING TO GET US ANYWHERE.
THEY DECIDED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
WE ARE A PEOPLE WHO CHOSE
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY ROOTED IN A
SENSE OF VIRTUE OVER DESPAIR AND
HOPELESSNESS.
AND WITH COURAGE, SACRIFICE, AND
AN INDOMITABLE SPIRIT AND AN
ABIDING FAITH IN GOD, WE WON OUR
INDEPENDENCE AND CREATED THE
GREATEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
POWERFUL FORCES IN TODAY'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THOUGH, ARE AT
WAR WITH THAT FUNDAMENTAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE AMERICAN
STORY.
IN FACT, MANY THINK THE FOUNDING
OF OUR COUNTRY WAS INHERENTLY
CORRUPT AND EVEN ILLEGITIMATE,
AND THEY HAVE MADE A DECISION TO
RUN AGAINST THAT VERSION OF
AMERICA.
IN THE ABSENCE OF AN ACTUAL PLAN
TO GROW AMERICAN PROSPERITY AND
KEEP US SAFE, DEMOCRATS ARE
EMBRACING VICTIMHOOD AS A
POLITICAL PLATFORM THIS MIDTERM
CYCLE.
DEMOCRAT STACEY ABRAMS IS
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR IN GEORGIA.
>> THE MIASMA OF FEAR THAT'S
CREATED BY VOTER SUPPRESSION IS
AS MUCH ABOUT TERRIFYING PEOPLE
ABOUT TRYING TO VOTE AS IT IS
ABOUT ACTUALLY BLOCKING THEIR
ABILITY TO DO SO.
>> Laura: WHAT IS SHE TALKING
ABOUT?
VOTER REGISTRATION HAS REACHED A
RECORD LEVEL IN GEORGIA, AND
THERE WAS A 75% VOTER
PARTICIPATION THERE IN 2016.
THE AVERAGE NATIONWIDE WAS ONLY
55%.
ABRAMS IS SELLING FEAR
VICTIMHOOD AT THE IDEA OF,
WEIGHT, ILLEGAL ALIENS VOTING?
>> THE THING IS, THE BLUE WAVE
IS AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IT'S WHITE, LATINO, ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER.
IT'S MADE UP OF THOSE WHO'VE
BEEN TOLD THEY ARE NOT WORTHY OF
BEING HERE.
IT'S COMPRISED OF THOSE WHO ARE
DOCUMENTED AND UNDOCUMENTED.
>> Laura: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
WAIT A MIDNIGHT TRAIN TO
GEORGIA.
DID YOU CATCH THAT?
SOUNDS LIKE ABRAMS HAD HER --
SAID THAT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WERE PART OF THE BLUE WAVE.
BE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE?
HOW DOES THAT NOT DILUTE THE
ILLEGAL VOTES OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS OF ALL COLORS AND ALL
BACKGROUNDS?
IT GETS WORSE.
IN MASSACHUSETTS, WHERE FOR
YEARS ELIZABETH WARREN HAS
SHAMELESSLY PEDDLED THE IDEA
THAT SHE'S A CHEROKEE INDIAN.
>> MY MB HAS WALKED BY THAT
PICTURE AT LEAST A
THOUSAND TIMES, REMARKED THAT
HER FATHER, HAD HIGH CHEEKBONES
LIKE ALL OF THE INDIANS.
BEING NATIVE AMERICAN HAS BEEN
PART OF MY STORY I GUESS SINCE
THE DAY I WAS BORN.
>> Laura: WAS SHE BORN IN
1985?
I THINK THAT'S WHEN SHE STARTED
TO TELL THE STORY.
ANYWAY, WARREN IS TRYING TO PLAY
THE VICTIM.
AFTER YEARS OF TAKING CRITICISM
FOR HER NATIVE AMERICAN CLAIMS,
WARREN, WITH AN ION 2020, TRIED
TO GET IT ALL OUT OF THE WAY.
SHE RELEASED AND EFFECTIVE VIDEO
DURING A DNA SPECIALIST.
>> WHAT ARE THE FACTS SAY?
>> YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE NATIVE
AMERICAN ANCESTRY IN YOUR
PEDIGREE.
>> SOME PEOPLE HAVE QUESTIONED
MY HERITAGE AND MY FAMILY
HISTORY.
MAYBE THEY DO IT TO INSULT ME.
MAYBE THEY DO IT TO DISTRACT
FROM THE KINDS OF CHANGES I'M
FIGHTING FOR.
>> Laura: ACCORDING TO A DNA
STUDY, ANALYZED BY STANFORD'S
CARLOS BUSTAMANTE, WHO WORKS FOR
23 AND MAY, THE ADVISOR OF
THAT COMPANY, WARREN IS POSSIBLY
1/1024, WHICH IS 0.09% NATIVE
AMERICAN.
THAT'S WHERE THE SCALE GOES.
IT GOES FROM .09% TO I DON'T
KNOW, LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," SCIENTIST
SAY THE AVERAGE
EUROPEAN-AMERICAN IS 0.18%
NATIVE AMERICAN.
SO THAT WOULD MAKE WARREN LESS
NATIVE AMERICAN THAN THE AVERAGE
EUROPEAN-AMERICAN.
WAIT A SECOND.
WHAT THE HECK HAPPENED TO
LIBERAL CONCERNS ABOUT CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION?
I GUESS THAT'S OUT THE WINDOW.
WARREN IS KIND OF A TYPICAL
DENIGRATE HER.
SHE'S RACIALLY OBSESSED, AND
LET'S FACE IT, IT'S EASIER THAN
BEING FACTUALLY INFORMED.
SHE IS WILLING TO SCAM THE
SYSTEM, IN THIS CASE PLAY IN
INDIAN TO GET A BOOST
PROFESSIONALLY OR IN THIS CASE
POLITICALLY.
TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY, HER DNA
SPECIALIST, CARLOS BUSTAMANTE,
FLATLEY ADMITTED THAT HE DIDN'T
EVEN USE NATIVE AMERICAN SAMPLES
FOR THE TEST.
SERIOUSLY?
TO MAKE UP FOR THE LACK OF THOSE
SAMPLES, HE IS ONE FROM MEXICO,
PERU, AND COLOMBIA.
KEEP THIS UP AND WARREN IS GOING
TO BE CLAIMING THAT SHE'S MORE
LATINA THAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ BY 2020.
SPEAKING OF LATINOS, A NEW
MIGRANT CARAVAN FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA, THE SECOND IN
SIX MONTHS, IS NOW HEADED UP
THROUGH MEXICO TO THE
UNITED STATES THIS WEEK.
IT ALREADY HAS 1600 MEMBERS.
NATURALLY, DEMOCRATS HAVE
STARTED THEIR OLD NARRATIVE
ABOUT TRUMP SEPARATING FAMILIES
OF THE BORDER.
IF ONLY THEY HAD THE SAME
CONCERN FOR AMERICANS BRUTALLY
VICTIMIZED BY ILLEGALS HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS, TWO
ILLEGALS HAVE COMMITTED VICIOUS
RAPES JUST IN THE NEW YORK AREA.
ONE FOLLOWED A NASSAU COUNTY
WOMAN HOME, KNOCKED HER OUT, AND
REPEATEDLY RAPED HER FOR ABOUT
AN HOUR.
THEN THERE'S SOMEONE WHO IS
THOUGHT TO BE A MEMBER OF MS-13.
HE BROKE INTO THE BEDROOM OF AN
11-YEAR-OLD GIRL HE DID NOT KNOW
AND RAPED HER ON A BUNK BED WITH
HER BROTHER BELOW THEM.
MEANWHILE, WE HEAR ALMOST
NOTHING ON THOSE STORIES OR SO
MANY MORE LIKE THEM FROM
DEMOCRATS WHO AT THE SAME TIME
AGONIZED OVER NONCITIZENS
OVERWHELMING OUR BORDER PATROL.
WHEN LESLIE STAHL TRIED TO MELT
HEARTS WITH HER FAMILY
SEPARATION NARRATIVE LAST NIGHT,
THE PRESIDENT SET HER STRAIGHT.
>> ARE YOU WILLING TO
REINSTITUTE THAT POLICY.
YOU SAID WE ARE LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING?
>> President Trump: WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THERE ARE CONSEQUENCES
FROM COMING INTO A COUNTRY,
NAMELY OUR COUNTRY, ILLEGALLY.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ASK IT
AGAIN.
>> President Trump: YOU DON'T
HAVE TO.
IT WAS THE SAME AS OBAMA.
>> Laura: DONALD TRUMP HAS
EXPOSED THE FRAUDULENT NATURE OF
THE LEFT-WING ARGUMENTS AND
THEIR WEAK NARRATIVES.
THERE IS A SUDDEN BOUNCE.
YOU FELT IN THE "60 MINUTES"
INTERVIEW LAST NIGHT.
THE LEFT IS FUMING THAT
60 MINUTES ACTUALLY AIR THE
INTERVIEW.
BUT HE HAS THE EXTRA BOUNCE IN
HIS STEP AND THE SENSE OF HIS
PARTY IS NOW ON THE RISE AGAIN.
FOLLOWING THE KAVANAUGH BATTLE,
YOU WOULD'VE THOUGHT SO THAT THE
DEMOCRATS MIGHT'VE GOTTEN THE
MESSAGE THAT VICTIMHOOD FOR
POLITICAL GAIN IS NOT A GREAT
STRATEGY.
IT WON'T WORK, AND IT HASN'T.
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS, THE
REPUBLICANS MAY HAVE FINALLY
FOUND THEIR GROOVE.
THEY ARE OUTSELLING THE PEACE,
PROSPERITY, AND SECURITY AGENDA
THAT TRUMP WON ON AND IS
DELIVERING ON.
I DON'T KNOW.
IN THE END, I THINK MOST